I'm with Dr. Rohin Francis,
cardiologist,
and we are about to disrespect the entire
medical and surgical professions,
by playing Operation in the
Old Operating Theatre in London.
But before we do that,
we do have a disclaimer.
We're using TENS machines today
to deliver a little electric shock
to one another,
to make the game
a little more interesting.
But these are medical devices.
We've taken all necessary precautions today,
and have medical assistance available,
so please don't try this at home.
Also, we have a cardiologist on site.
That's right.
If I have a cardiac arrest,
I will resuscitate myself.
One rule we should mention
to the audience...
we did try this,
just playing regular Operation,
as you're allowed to
in the rules.
And we both cleared the board
without ever getting shocked.
This is too easy, Rohin.
This is too easy.
Well, I mean, yeah.
You've just discovered
the secret of surgery. It is pretty easy.
So, new rule:
We can only float our hand
above the board.
We cannot rest on the table.
This is gonna suck...!
Tom, we need to maintain
strict asepsis here, so...
Yep, yep.
So, we've washed our hands,
but I need to don my
surgical cap.
Come for the occasion.
This is the one I use at work.
We've only tested these on the lowest power,
and we are now...
gone quite high, so...
Rock-paper-scissors to start?
Let's do it.
Agh...
You know what, you can go first.
Good luck. Pick a card.
It's quite chilly in here.
It is.
♪ (horn crescendo into pulsing synth)
I'm getting my excuses out early.
Charlie Horse for 400 points.
That is...
And...
Ah, just there.
Is that, like, some American...?
That is an American term
for a cramp, I think.
I see, alright.
Some sort of cramp. I don't know.
Alright. Good luck.
This is excellent.
The minute I see
the tiniest bit of light on there!
Oh yeah, we're controlling
each other's TENS units, by the way.
It slid.
It slid underneath there,
hasn't it?
Okay...
(breathily) Hoooh...
Oh, I can't.
You're gonna have to rotate.
[BUZZ]
Oh! Ack, Jesus!
Ah...
That's a good start.
You say that, and now I've gotta
try and do the exact same thing.
So, um, good luck.
I've loosened it for you.
You have.
It's easier.
Alright.
Right. I'm poised.
Oh, you see,
there's a leg just there.
♪ (horn crescendo into pulsing synth)
That's— That's fine, that's fine.
It's so difficult
without leaning on anything.
(sighs)
♪ (high percussion loop added)
Can I rotate it?
[BUZZ]
Gaaah! (huffs)
(laughs)
Mmph!
This is good.
'Kay. 'Kay. 'Kay.
(chuckles)
(inhales sharply)
Right, so...
I'm just gonna put that there,
'cause apparently this is
gonna take a few attempts!
Your— Your shot.
Do you wanna come back to it, as like,
the beast we couldn't defeat?
Okay, my pick then.
Bread Basket for 1000.
Okay, that's a nice, big space there.
It's also a nice, big... orifice.
There's not much to...
Well...
I realise that's a technical term,
but still!
♪ (cello/synth drone)
Hooh...
Okay, I'm poised.
What do I...
How do I even grab on to that?
A good surgeon wouldn't ask
these questions, Tom.
I'm not a good surgeon!
(music fades)
There we go, okay.
Ohh, well done, well done.
Hoooh!
That's fine. There was something,
but as soon as you moved it,
it was something to grab onto there.
That's fine.
Alright, your pick.
Okay. Ah, cheap one.
Only 300.
Writer's Cramp. Now...
♪ (cello/synth drone)
Ohh! Ohh!
This is the one I'd...
spotted earlier as being problematic.
♪ (echoed percussion)
(chuckles) Let's be honest.
Everything we're doing here today
is problematic.
Alright.
Uh...
Oh man.
♪ (hollow synth crescendo)
(huffs slowly)
(music fades)
There you go.
Hooh.
Nice.
I've warmed up now,
channelling the surgical gods.
You wanna flip that over,
take the points.
Take the points.
For 200— Oh, it's the Pulled Muscle.
It's the elastic band.
I think that's easy.
I think that's an easy one.
Eh, I'm not so sure.
(whispers) Okay.
♪ (ambient synth)
♪ (heavy synth beat added)
Okay.
(music fades)
Ohh, we might need to
ramp the difficulty up on this.
♪ (low string pulses)
Left-handed?
'Kay, with no resting.
Left-handed.
...Okay.
Your card.
Yeah... (stammers)
Okay, Butterflies in the Stomach.
That's fine. That's an easy one.
You can do that left-handed.
No worries.
That's what I'm feeling right now.
[BUZZ]
Ack! Oh, it's the wrong hand.
(both laugh)
Pick up the—
[BUZZ]
That... does not count.
That does not count!
I didn't do it.
(both laugh)
Right, here we go.
♪ (low string pulses)
Okay. (scoffs)
How do I...? Nngh.
(sighs)
(music fades)
Well, I'm getting humiliated here.
Wishbone, 600.
That does not look nice.
No, I think.
Alright.
♪ (cello/synth drone)
This is, of course, entirely
anatomically correct.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yep.
Humans famously do have
a wishbone in the sternum.
♪ (synth intensifies)
[BUZZ]
(music halts)
Uh, you didn't— That didn't hit.
Nothing, nothing?
Do you wanna try that again?
'Kay, you're gonna have to turn that up.
Okay.
Alright.
Gaaaah!
(chuckles)
(groans, inhales sharply)
I'm-a turn this one up
as well, 'cause...
that only seems fair.
Mine was working fine.
Yeah! (breathes heavily)
♪ (cello/synth drone)
Yeah, this left-handed thing is
a bit of a curveball here.
Yeah, yeah.
Do you ever get asked
to do surgery left-handed?
It's not a common request.
No.
Uh...
It's the rotation.
♪ (echoing percussion added)
I don't know if the camera is catching this,
but it is completely in the wrong position.
♪ (synth arpeggio)
Wow, I didn't realise how bad
my left hand is.
I'm trying to see the light under you.
♪ (music intensifies)
Oh, if you get this...
(whispers) Oh, it got stuck.
Ohh!
♪ (hollow synth drone, music fades)
Success.
I heard a noise there,
and I nearly gave you the shock,
but it wasn't the light,
that was just you scraping past the...
Yeah.
Alright, well done.
I think we're...
Difficult extrication.
Alright, that's one back to you,
and it's your card.
Right, okay.
Broken Heart. Very appropriate.
Uh-ooh.
So I think that'll be easy,
once you get it in position.
Familiar territory.
Yeah. Yeah.
...Oh!
(belly laughs)
That was what I was saying.
I don't know how well it's shown up on camera.
That is tucked
away from you, over there.
♪ (horn crescendo into pulsing synth)
Okay.
Good luck.
I'm gonna have to try this
when I go back to work.
Just say, "I'm just gonna be
left-handed today."
Just hope patients are understanding.
♪ (high percussion loop added)
Nothing to grip onto.
(laughs)
Keep an eye on that light.
I seem to have pushed it further.
Yes, you have.
Yeah, you absolutely have.
I'm slightly worried in this position,
that if you—
[BUZZ]
Aah! Jeez, that is a lot stronger.
(belly laughs)
Oh, and the— the—
The shock has pushed it
into a nice position now.
(chuckles)
(sighs) Alright, okay.
♪ (ambient synth)
(both breathe loudly)
Left hand. Left hand.
Your left hand.
♪ (heavy percussion beat added)
It's not in a nice position at all.
There's nothing to grip onto,
until I...
♪ (music intensifies)
[BUZZ]
AAAAAAH!
That is a lot! That is a lot!
(chuckles)
Hooooh!
Alright. That goes on—
That goes on the bonus pile, for later.
Oh, that sticks around, doesn't it?
That.... mmmh.
It would be good if it's on
the hand we're using.
'Cause then...
(sighs)
Alright. Yeah. Yeah.
Do you want to do that?
Shall we switch it over?
Yeah.
Nnngh!
Before we started doing this...
We started on minimum,
just to be safe.
And we're now about...
half the way up.
(inhales deeply)
Not sure I wanna go any further with that.
No, that's plenty, I think.
Alright, whose— whose card is it?
It's your card.
Right, okay, okay.
♪ (pulsing synth percussion)
Adam's Apple. Uh...
No, I like that. I like that.
It's got a little stalk.
It's got a stalk to grip onto,
so left-handed.
(whispers)
Left-handed, here we go.
(softly) Left-handed,
not resting on the table.
(music climaxes, fades)
(deflates)
That was speed.
Congratulations, surgeon.
Speed got me that one.
Speed— It was just— (laughs)
I wasn't resting my hand.
I was resting the tweezers.
And just like — (grunt) —
just pull that out and hope.
Speed is often the strategy I go for, actually.
(cackles)
♪ (jittery atonal strings)
Just in and out.
Your card.
Right.
♪ (percussion hit into pulsing music)
You need this piece.
Funny Bone.
Oh dear. That's another one
that's slid.
Uh, I think you got a
nice, wide aperture there.
I think you'll be fine.
The humerus.
Yes.
Oh, no...
(laughs)
I'm worried that if your arm flails,
it'll hit me in the face now.
Nicely done.
(music fades)
That puts the score at 2000 to 1300.
Oh, I'm way behind.
No, you're only one Broken Heart behind.
That's your territory.
Yeah, okay.
Alright, for 200...
Spare Ribs.
♪ (pulsing music)
(both moan)
This looks like...
Ooh, I don't like that.
..it could have some challenges here.
I don't like that at all.
You know, some people
do actually have spare ribs.
(music pauses)
Really?
You can have extra ribs.
Huh.
Cervical rib.
I have to move that somehow.
(music resumes)
Oh, that's... worse.
That is... disaster.
That is much worse!
(exhales shakily)
(whispers) Ah, well done.
♪ (percussion hit into jittery strings)
Aaaah!
Oooh!
Snatching defeat from the jaws of victory.
♪ (strings intensify)
[BUZZ]
NNAANNGH-mmh!
(breathes heavily)
Well done for...
not using any expletives on that.
Mhm. Mhm.
That's impressive discipline.
Have a try!
Spare Ribs.
♪ (dramatic sting into pulsing percussion)
(groans hoarsely)
Oh, well, you've...
I've left that in a very good position
for you, haven't I?
I don't know, 'cause...
getting on the side of that
would be challenging.
(mutters)
It's your Z-axis that's
gonna be the problem here.
If you go too low, you're gonna hit.
If you can just— You're not resting?
You're not resting, okay.
This is tough. I think I might
push it back in.
I think I might just...
put it back in the middle.
♪ (percussive rhythm changes)
Brave. Very brave.
That looks like a terrible position
from my angle.
That's somehow much worse.
That's much, much worse!
[BUZZ]
(grunts)
Whoa, you left it on there.
Yeah, I wasn't sure it was working
for a moment there.
So, you know what?
I think we should
push that a little bit higher.
Much like my voice in that sentence,
which clearly was not convinced
about that.
I'm up to that setting.
Oh, my goodness me.
You've gone... full send.
Right, well, we've got quite a few.
Your card.
Water on the Knee for 500.
♪ (growling synth into drone)
Oh, that's fine.
You got a bucket handle to grab onto.
You're gonna be fine.
Oh dear, oh dear.
Right.
Okay, I'm just gonna go for
your speed approach.
(music fades)
Whew.
Orthopedic surgery is very easy.
(chortles)
You know I'm gonna get a complaint
from one orthopedic surgeon about that.
Only one? At least a few.
(sighs) For 200, Wrenched Ankle.
♪ (brief synth drone)
These are all very American cards. Alright.
Well, you're paying for
your surgery here, Tom.
Did that not give you a clue
it's an American game?
Fair, alright.
♪ (drone resumes)
(breathes deeply)
I'm poised, I'm ready.
Oh, I don't like
the look of this one at all.
That's...
You can get that fine.
Who prepared this game?
We did. We literally did it ourselves.
Who was— Oh right.
I have to reach in over here.
No, this is a disa—
I'm just gonna put it in now, I think.
Don't you dare.
♪ (pulsing rhythm added)
[BUZZ]
a-BAAAA-HA!
(grunts, inhales)
Might've just hit myself
in the teeth with that.
That was—
That was deeply unpleasant.
We're not going any higher than that.
That's— That's a lot.
That's a lot.
Can I recommend not putting it
that near your face?
(wheezes)
Okay, right.
♪ (ambient rhythm)
Oh, I'm moving the table.
♪ (rhythm changes, builds)
[BUZZ]
Agh, Jesus!
(laughs)
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so...
We have these four cards
as the ones that defeated us.
I think we should just
reiterate that, you know,
right-handed we'd
breeze this game, and any—
We actually filmed a
right-handed version of this,
and neither of us got shocked at all.
And I want any prospective patients
watching to know that
if you ever meet me in hospital,
that I'm not gonna do it left-handed.
Yeah, like the— the—
The— The version of this that didn't air
was the version where
we got to this point
having just gone, "This is fine."
(sighs) Okay.
I'm gonna suggest...
that we each get one more shot
at each of those.
Yeah.
'Cause I think...
I don't really wanna do this
that much more.
So I'm still—
So I'm only on 1800 here.
Uh, I'm only on 2000.
There's only 200 in it.
Okay.
So...
I'm mostly in the lead 'cause
I got lucky and got Bread Basket,
which was an easy and
high-paying one.
Urologists do earn
quite a lot of money.
I might be slightly brain-addled here.
Give me a mo.
Right, so — (stammers)
There are four cards there
we both failed.
I'm gonna suggest:
re-shuffle them...
Mhm.
Play 'em once more through.
If we still can't do 'em...
that's it, it's out of the game.
Patient's dead.
Alright.
Sometimes you lose.
Just, you know, one of those things.
(chuckles) I'm glad you're the one
making these jokes!
Alright, now...
I'm-a shuffle these while looking up,
'cause I can see amounts on them.
I'm gonna put them in...
this order here.
And you're going first.
Okay.
And it's the 700.
Well, I think I know what that one...
Broken Heart.
It's Broken Heart.
♪ (horn crescendo into pulsing synth)
My hand is kind of tingling now!
Yeah, yeah!
Sticks around, doesn't it?
It's progressively getting harder.
Hooh, okay. It's not
a great angle for you, that.
For me, I reckon I could
grab that quite easy.
'Cause I can see
what you can tweeze.
Yeah, let's cut this faffing.
That's okay. You can see what you
can tweeze there from my angle.
You've gotta lean over.
I can't see the light, and if I—
Thing is, if I lean over
to look at the light,
there's a chance
you will hit me in the face
if you get it.
And that's...
♪ (conclusive percussion)
Smooth.
Success.
Puts you in the lead, I think.
Right. So that's...
I've lost count.
2500.
2500 plays 2000 exactly.
Oh, and this is only a 200 one.
Wrenched Ankle. Alright.
♪ (dramatic orchestra hit)
Oh, it's not an easy one.
It's not an easy one. Here we go.
♪ (pulsing synth rhythm)
(sighs) Left hand, free-floating.
Oh my...
I'll have to come around for this.
That moves?
Just rest your elbow on the patient.
I should point out.
This is a replica table. We are not playing
on the original operating table.
(music intensifies)
Whoa.
(shivers) 'Kay.
I can't rest the other hand,
can I? Agh...
You can rest the other hand.
[BUZZ]
Didn't work.
Didn't work? Okay.
GAH!
Mmmh! (breathes heavily)
Ah, the calm decorum of an
operating theatre.
It's yours for 200, if you can get it.
Uh, can I just pass? (chuckles)
No! No, you can't!
♪ (pulsing percussion)
This is...
this is not my... my field.
(softly) Oh, this is— Okay.
♪ (strings added in slow crescendo)
Keep an eye on that light.
The slightest twinkle...
[BUZZ]
(grunts) Jesus...!
Well, that one's gone.
That is not getting fixed!
That one is out of play.
Your ankle is toast, my friend.
Are you on 2500?
2500.
I need both of these.
I need both of these to win.
But it's my card.
Boom. Go on.
Charlie Horse.
Agh, that's the one I— That's the early one
that I really badly messed up, isn't it?
That looks impossible.
If I mess this up, it's your game.
Simple as that.
Okay. Bit of drama.
If I get this, I still need to get
the next one to win.
I was leading earlier.
(sighs) Alright.
Did you just turn that up?!
No, it's the...
(both laugh)
I thought about it.
I did think about it.
Don't you dare! Hoooh!
♪ (ambient synths)
Oh, that looks— Oh my god.
Right, okay.
♪ (jittery strings added)
Let's just try and move it.
Let's just try and...
♪ (music intensifies)
(whispers) Okay.
That's in position.
You've got a loose definition of
"in position" there.
It's not rotated, okay?
It's— It's— It's—
You're losing him, doctor.
You're not helping!
You're not helping.
(music slowly crescendos)
[BUZZ]
GAAAAAaaaaaa!
Well, that's a fitting end to the game.
I regret everything about this!
I mean, I'm just relieved.
It would've been pretty humiliating
if I had lost.
And, uh, I got to shock Tom Scott.
And you know,
how many people can say that?
Thanks for playing...!
Nurse!
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]